alors monsieur le directeur
alors le je m'étonne après vous avoir
écrit deux fois
d'être restée sans réponse je suis
monsieur poulin
je vous ai écrit que j'étais père de
famille de sept enfants
sous mer depuis quatre ans
et que je recherchais un an + jeu
solliciter un emploi de gardien dans
votre établissement
par monsieur poulet à des lettres comme
ça avoue on écrivait souvent ben oui
c'est souvent disons que enfin la
plupart du temps disons que je me
dérange quand même plutôt moi même un
qu'est ce que vous cherchez pas le type
d'emploi bagis rechercher un petit peu
dans plusieurs branches j'ai cherché
comme chauffeur puisque j'ai tous les
permis poids lourd je me suis débrouillé
pour
obtenir le permis de transport en commun
j'ai cherché dans les chauffeurs
d'autocars aussi j'ai cherché dans les
entreprises de gardiennage puisque j'ai
même été jusqu'à adressa un chien pour
bien deux
d'avoir une chance de plus bon j'ai
cherché partout j'ai même chercher dans
des entreprises comme manoeuvre s'il
fallait quand je vois que cette femme
qui écrit les lettres pourquoi c'est pas
ça pas disons que j'ai le problème voyez
moi on est un jeune j'étais très à
droite à gauche
j'ai le problème de de ne pas savoir
écrire
famille vous madame gondjout qui fait
des lettres vous l'aidez beaucoup votre
mari a trouvé un emploi mais c'est tout
ce que ce qu'il faut pour faire
pour l'aider à trouver un travail
il écrit tout partout en attendant
je n'avais pas de réponses n'ont jamais
joué
j'ai monde qui coûtent pas là bas alors
à chaque fois je peux pas il faut
toujours que je revienne ici pour vider
l'eau dans les égouts alors si je laisse
le glow écoulés sur le trottoir c'est
tout noyé alors on me dit que je suis
sain
alors après les enfants ils viennent y
patauge dans l'autre tout ce qui s'en
suit alors j'ai demandé à faire des
réparations ici pour le logement et je
mets personne qui est venue
alors j'ai ça répare et j'ai jemma
cheminée en haut j'ai ma chambre faton
logement est arrivé
vous êtes inquiets des fois pour vos
enfants
oui quand même pas si bien
enfin michelin perd quand même ça vous
arrive des matins de savoir comment les
nourrir
oui ça m'arrive quelquefois des sols je
me dis pas comment je vais faire et me
reste tout juste pour aller le lendemain
on mari se débrouille tout le temps pour
eux pour essayer de trouver quelque
chose pour nous aider à survivre un
petit peu c'est très dur et on vous dit
que parfois il vous reste tout juste
pour le lendemain c'est combien argent
pour la plongée pas plus que
70 francs quelques fois par jour
quand on est à 9 9 personnes
or moi je suis boulanger suis dans un
pays minier ce sont des gens malheureux
ils demandent qu'à travailler n'ont pas
de travail neuf fois sur dix on supprime
demande de faire du crédit j'en fais
j'en paie les conséquences pour la bonne
raison que la commandement ici tu es
reçues on a il faut pas payer c'est un
commandement d'huissier on ne l'avait
pas payé ses impôts s'est forgé ces gens
là travaillent n'ont pas de travail ça
pas vous payer comment voulez vous il y
avait un temps 7 est florissant les
mines ça marchait bien maintenant faire
tout alors que c'est savez ça fait des
chômeurs ça fait chier chômeurs et à
leur donne de l'argent au chômage un an
ciment j'ignore combien on me faire
travailler tout le monde le travail est
mal rétribués comment voulez vous que ça
arrive tout le monde est révolté moi
c'est pareil qui fuguent équipage et
revit ici bon dans un pays minier grave
en 30 40 le reste me reste flou bon bah
la rage me proches voient quelques
petits moelleux retenu les enfants
venant à petits pas c'est vrai c'est pas
vrai monsieur il ne distribue pas ça
fait mal au ventre au quartz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai répondu d'abord des mariés là pour
vous dire déjà comme une idée du matos
alors je lève tout le temps du matin au
soir ça n'arrête pas des fois je m'aime
je crie sur dix qui salit pas de temps
et tout arrive pas faux tout temps que
j'allais machine sinon mon âge une
minute
[Musique]
brochot fait des fois vous allez voler
du bois
j'ai fait mon installation moi-même de
radiateurs de chauffage central dans
toutes les pièces
quelquefois c'est des gens qui me
demandent la bat ana outre les gênes
quelquefois je suis obligé de me servir
en plus de ces shows comme tout le monde
si je le trouve paul bon bah je vais
chercher l'eau
[Musique]
alors là monsieur coup là vous faites
vos comptes qu'est ce que vous avez
comme comme ressource bien en ce moment
alors comme ressource régulière les
allocations familiales eux strictement
et
catherine
600 francs je
savais qu en vous écoutant et beaucoup
de gens qui vont se dire finalement sur
des gens qui vivent de leurs enfants
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je suis pas
d'accord
nous enfin sur on vit pour nos enfants
quoi moi aussi je resterai c'est pour
mes enfants parce que j'en ai vraiment
marre comme je dirais qu'il ya des gens
qui vont penser que nous en effet
beaucoup d'enfants simplement pour les
allocations familiales c'est pas sono
carmaux citoyens via moi pensent comment
peut-on faire vivre cet enfant dé 14 ans
par mois comme grosse dépense on a le
problème de l'électricité
comme ici j'ai une facture nous qui
donne pas droit à ces immigrants plus
une facture d'électricité de 57 milles
sur pattes sur ce que certains pensent
ça prend déjà un coin
attention
du raku cyclonique pour d une crise qui
dure un goût bien j'ai ceci son salut en
tranches avec eux mon père mes frites
du bouillon de légumes
témoigne aris pop et même le quatuor
bon gentil parce que j'ai pas les moyens
vous savez ils sont dans trois écoles
différentes
alors on s'en sortait avec des sommes de
250 mille francs pour un seul repas le
boulanger ça nous coûte combien parmi
150 pas mise au point si vous voulez une
fois que j'ai payé toutes les factures
sur les allocations il nous reste
strictement rien alors c'est le problème
des brouilles et va tous les jours
j'essaie de gagner 100 105 enfants
avec des solutions qui ne soient vos
quelquefois pas pas tout à fait normal
je le reconnais mais enfin
bon ça ne regarde pas rentrer à la
maison à part tes frères
[Musique]
sylvie s'il faut prendre un fusil de
chasse et puis partir dans les champs le
soir en boîte et en bas il n'ya pas et
il faut que mes enfants y mange et je
les ai pas et je n'ai pas d'autre
solution d'ailleurs vous l'avez fait
récemment vous cet intéressement ah oui
oui d'ailleurs dans la région disant que
j'ai eu des certains petits problèmes
avec des présidents société de chasse et
plus des gains une fois vous avez été
tenté par des poules ouais ouais ben là
disons que j'étais parti en ce moment là
on était vraiment ce qui s'appelle sens
d'argent et puis il y avait une grosse
entreprise dernière donc je suis parti
j'ai pris ça cool puis quand je suis
rentré chez moi
avec ma femme qui avait touché à un
petit mandat
je voulais pas les prendre c'était pas
du vol il fallait qu'il donne à manger à
mes gosses
donc comme on avait eu ce mandat et puis
que avec subtilement d'un bon vin ça
nous permettait de vivre de trois jours
j'avais le temps de revoir autre chose
devant moi donc j'ai pris l'épaule je
suis parti trouver le propriétaire puis
les ai rendu
[Musique]
il y avait un certain temps où j'étais
découragé d'ailleurs j'ai sombré un
petit peu dans la boisson j'ai eu pas
mal de trucs j'ai essayé de me suicider
il ya à peu près à peu près il ya quatre
ans après la perte d'emploi
ben ça s'est passé que
avec elle-même à bout de nerfs au bout
du rouleau il s'arrêtait sur le trottoir
de 20
et il a tapé au carreau
et il dit qu'il me dit tu vois c'est la
dernière fois que tu me vois kindy
sa dernière focus vois tu me verras plus
j'en ai marre et je veux en finir
moi je savais pas je crois il me disais
que vous soyez là que je savais pas
alors il a pris son temps où les moudre
à son tour ils étaient tous jusqu'au
bout de la route là bas
[Musique]
et il est rentré dedans
il y avait déjà en train de le ranimer
ils l'ont ramené ici il empochait et le
médecin lui ai fait une piqûre pour le
cannois
[Musique]
lequel alger ap ap hanoi
c'était comment la vie heureuse
la vie heureuse disons qu'ils étaient
une période de groulx ont travaillé tous
les deux bon ben là il y avait pas de
problème on n'avait pas les soucis
d'argent
on pouvait offrir aux enfants ce qu'est
ce qu'ils avaient besoin donc je pense
que pour nous c'était une période de la
plus formidable quoi
moi j'étais je travaillais de nuit
seul petit problème qu'avait c'est que
quand ma femme s'en aller travailler le
matin bon bah ouais c'était l'heure où
je rentrais donc je voulais pas me
coucher je m'occupais des enfants lui
dit je vais préparer sur guinée quand
elle rentre et l'après midi de son
travail et puis rebelote je les couche
et l'après midi c'est elle qui
s'occupait de mon le soir avant de
partir au boulot et là je pense qu'on a
été retenue puis bon bah on avait un
matériel
caméra super 8 et puis on filme et
l'évolution des enfants tout ça au mans
on a gardé ses films l'armé disant que
la caméra et on n'a plus les moyens de
garder ça
[Musique]
et
on
bon bah les enfants on les voit grandir
alors on les voit sur leur vélo le
premier vélo
ils ont en plus la chance de le passer
parce qu'on a plus de matériel là on a
été obligé de tout vendre
et j'ai toujours regardé les films parce
qu'un jour on sait si on sonne l'orage
traces qu'il faut
une belle ligne vous n'etes et salariés
tous les deux bon bah on pouvait se
permettre pas mal de choses
joli thouars aux joies et toi rose et
puis on a eu un appartement on était
bien et tout en un le chauffage central
et puis c'est là qu'on a commencé à voir
des tuiles bon j'ai failli perdre mon
garçon et à l'âge de six mois
il avait une déshydratation avec les
chevaux le chauffage central dans les
appartements
et c'était juste le soir de noël alors
on à effet a beau sapin grand sapin avec
des boules et où est mon mari était
retournée là rentrer à la maison elle
était retournée chez elle plus quoi
faire alors c'est là que ça commence et
leurs
pistolets ça va être un des rêves à oui
ça ça ça ne m'est mambo et ouais
j'aurais levé quelque chose bête
jeu voudriez
je voudrais être quelqu'un de surnaturel
qui est je sais pas comment expliquer ça
mon rêve moi c'est d'aider tout le monde
de ne plus voir personne de malheureux
alors je me prends pour à superman pour
pour quelqu'un qui peut aider des autres
qui peut qui peut faire tout ce qu'il
veut ça ça m'arrive toutes les nuits
mais d'ailleurs y est c'est vrai je dors
je voudrais aider les gens s'ils s'y
passe aussi par malheur à la télévision
je vois des gosses malheureux que je
vois des gens massacrés ou bien que
c'est tout le soir il faut que je rêve
oublions pas pour autant les vrais
démunis la crise économique les frappe
de plein fouet ne s'agit pas seulement
des poches de pauvreté traditionnel
malheureusement en france et aussi c'est
nous on va donc beaucoup de chômeurs
jean marc dubois
cette image c'est l'image classique
quotidienne du 2 mars mais maintenant
dans le métro il y a une autre image
celle ci dans les jeunes ce correctement
vêtus de chars et qui sont sans emploi
sans ressources sans domicile
avec un travail mais ils l'ont perdu
comment vous réagissez monsieur poulin
devant la télévision
disons que
il ya des choses que je trouve aberrante
legault qui est réduit à la mendicité à
tendre la main dans la rue je n'arrive
pas à comprendre ça c'est c'est pas
possible c'est s'il n'est admissible moi
personnellement j'en arriverais pas là
je peux pas comprendre qu'on puisse
laisser des gens comme ça je sais pas
moi quand j'ai voulu on entend parler
d'une femme qui couche en dessous d'un
pont avec ses causes pendant trois mois
ci à venteuges et ça ne doit plus
exister deux jours on se dit civilisé
mais je sais pas moi on est pire que des
bêtes on ne sait plus personne
maintenant un vrai pas l'impression que
vous venez de voir quelque chose qui
vous menace
ben si moi je crois que j'arriverai pas
là parce que plutôt qu'allemande hui je
préfère c'est pauvre je peux faire mais
fut georges est allé puiser tout
jean besré table la main
non ça c'est pas possible
profil bas
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]